who's the last person you'll text before
going into the game come on I'll be
honest I'm probably not texting anybody
I generally don't talk to people before
the game my sister probably my
girlfriend my brother Eric cuz we share
playing in NFL together so he'll be here
in the stands and get special moment for
us I'm usually off my phone all of game
day I don't shoot that many
texts maybe I'm just bad at responding
to text my mom say why Mom she always
the first one to text me but I always
wait till I'm about to get on to the
field to my brother my mom my mom always
gives me a little pet talk text mom my
dad I us to text my mom right before she
sent me a nice
little speak